[Musique]
ça arrive parfois sur les mers
un jour un cargo une patrouille de
police maritine découvre un bateau au
large sans personne à bord
un bateau fantôme
[Musique]
les journaux s'empare de la faire chacun
veut savoir si c'est une disparition
volontaire un accident ou bien oeuvre
en australie un an après la découverte
d'un bateau fantôme c'est tribunal de
donner la clé de l'énigme
c'est une grosse affaire parce qu'elle
est mystérieuse
trois hommes faisait une croisière sur
la côte ouest et d'après ce qu'ont dit
les familles ça devait être le grand
voyage de leur vie
quelque part en mer ces trois hommes ont
disparu soudainement il n'y a eu aucun
signal de détresse le bateau est en
parfaite état excepté une voile déchirée
c'est très bizarre et tout le monde veut
savoir ce qui s'est passé et attend des
réponses
ça faisait une éternité que claye
robinson n'avait pas revu autant de
confrères il faut dire que cette drôle
d'affaires alerté tous les journalistes
du queensland et même les télés
nationales
alors monsieur tonnes stade aujourd'hui
ses grands jours grand jour oui on
espère enfin que quelque chose va en
sortir
chen a porté un carton de correspondance
appartenant à son père disparu or aider
la cour à y voir plus clair
[Musique]
avant
c'est un drôle de procès les boks sont
vides il n'y a ni témoin ni accusés et
on n'a jamais retrouvé les victimes
nous ouvrons une enquête sur la
disparition de derek charles baptême de
james alfredsson stead et de peter
johnson steyn
fait représenter devant ce tribunal
enregistré sous le numéro 98 62
ce qu'on sait avec certitude c'est que
le case 2 à catamaran que les trois
hommes venaient d'acheter a été retrouvé
au large de townsville
à coup sûr la semaine de débats et de
délibération va bousculer le train train
de la petite cité balnéaire qui fait
face à la grande barrière de corail
[Musique]
le mystère daoud fives c'est comme ça
que les journaux baptisé la sphère des
centaines de sites internet ont envahi
la toile avec des informations plus ou
moins farfelues des disparitions il y en
a déjà eu dans le coin mais cette fois
ci trois plaisanciers d'un coup par
temps calme et sous un beau soleil ça
interroge tout le monde
[Musique]
juste une heure pour enregistrer son
commentaire les montées son sujet qui va
tourner en boucle ce soir dans les
journaux de la télé régionale
bon ok crevier jusque là
il ya juste un an peter thorne stade ici
à gauche le skipper derek batani james
le frère de peter tonnes stead ont
disparu
ils avaient embarqué pour une croisière
avec le catamaran de 10 m de monsieur
bataille depuis un lit beach
le voyage était supposé durer six à huit
semaines mais cinq jours après le départ
le voilier été retrouvés dérivant au
large de townsville sans aucune trace
des trois hommes
[Musique]
les pare battages était sortie
qui se fait généralement lorsqu un yacht
ou un voilier vient s'amarrer bord à
bord
[Musique]
on a donc pensé au début qu'un autre
bateau était peut-être venu leur rendre
visite
mais l' enquête n'a pas confirmé cette
hypothèse
ce qui est étrange aussi c'est que
l'ordinateur de bord fonctionner
normalement et que le couvert et emi
on ne sait toujours pas ce qui s'est
passé et on espère que ce procès
apportera toutes les réponses
le décor est un peu déconcertant pour
une série noire le gaz de nunavik et pas
dans les brumes d'un archipel isolé ou
au large d'un fameux triangle
les whitsundays c'est un peu la
croisière de rêve sur prospectus un
petit paradis mais voilà les soupçons
des bruits courent et viennent troubler
ses eaux limpides
[Musique]
et
oh
oui
mes trois amis ont-ils été victime d'un
meurtre
les corps ou les affaires des trois
hommes auraient pu remonter à la surface
mais rien absolument rien n'a été
retrouvé
alors les quais grouille de détectives
amateurs des plaisanciers du coin qui
ont tous leur petite idée sur le drame
ça pourrait être une affaire de drogue
regardez ont un rendez vous avec un gars
ils font un échange ok merci j'ai ce
qu'il faut
au revoir et les balances à 75 milles
derrière la barrière de corail
je veux dire qu'il y aurait eu du rififi
avec des armes
justement ça met du piment à la faire
quand on sait qu'ils avaient un calibre
44 à bord avec des centaines de
munitions
les fouilles calibre 44 et une énorme
quantité de cartouches chine posent des
questions sinon c'était peut-être une
dispute qui a mal tourné quand on vit
dans un espace étroit et qu'on n'a pas
l'habitude ce sont des choses qui
arrivent et quand même si peu de temps
après le début du voyage
non
à une haute et auris et qu' il aurait
peut-être pu se retrouver coincé sur un
récif où un banc de sable
j'ai vérifié et à ce moment là la marée
était basse
ils sont peut-être redescendu tous les
trois pour pousser
et comme le bateau avait toute sa
voilure il a très bien pu se libérer
partir d'un seul club et les gars n'ont
jamais pu le rattraper
les rumeurs se propagent comme une
méchante tâche d'huile sur les rivages
du queensland escroquerie trang
piraterie
depuis plus d'un siècle quand un
équipage disparaît sur la mer et que
tout le monde s'interroge un nom
toujours le même nom remonte à la
surface
aujourd'hui le tribunal a dit que cette
affaire était très semblable à celle de
la marie céleste
l'équipage a disparu sans laisser de
traces c'est un mystère total
forcément la cour à rapprocher cette
affaire avec celle de la marie céleste
lamari céleste c'est la disparition la
plus célèbre des annales maritime parmi
tous les bateaux fantômes c'est celui
qui a fait le plus parler de lui la
sphère la plus mystérieuse la plus
étrange que la mère ait jamais inspiré
au large de gibraltar en décembre 1872
une brigantine est retrouvé en bon état
mais vide une dizaine d'hommes
d'équipage commandée par le capitaine
briggs s'est volatilisé le journal de
bord intacte relate une mer calme 100
milles au sud-ouest des açores et puis
et puis plus rien
quand les premiers sauveteurs découvrent
le bateau à la dérive plusieurs détails
les intrigues
il n'y a aucune trace de lutte et dans
la cabine du capitaine un thé encore
chaud est servi
le rocher a bien changé depuis un siècle
gibraltar gagne sur la mer et dans les
hauteurs mais certains accents semble
éternelle
à l'époque de la marie céleste ça devait
ressembler à ça quand la colonie montrer
son attachement à la couronne
d'angleterre et à son gouverneur
[Musique]
dis moi tu enregistres est archi tout ce
qui se passe son cas lui en amateur
si guy mouette avait vécu à la fin du
19e siècle c'est sûr il aurait pris son
calepin et aurait couru sur le port un
fameux matin d'hiver
[Musique]
le mystère de la marie céleste commence
en décembre 1872
l'équipage d'un bateau le diy gracia a
trouvé la marie céleste abandonné en mer
à cette époque gibraltar était une
amirauté britannique
et le tribunal a ordonné une enquête
pour déterminer les circonstances selon
lesquelles la marie céleste avait été
trouvé sans personne à bord
dis moi tu s'est toujours passionné pour
cette histoire de bateaux fantômes
d'ailleurs ici tout le monde connaît
plus ou moins les détails d'une affaire
vieille de 140 ans et en particulier au
sein du gibraltar chronicle le premier
témoin du rocher le journal local vient
de fêter son bicentenaire
et à cette époque le gibraltar chronicle
relater toutes les allées et venues des
bateaux c'est vrai c'était la gazette
officielle c'était un peu son rôle la
gazette détail est aussi les chargement
des navires ce que qu'on voyait là marie
céleste était assez étrange sans
éveiller l'intérêt
ce n'est pas la première fois que
dominique soeur le rédacteur en chef
reçoit jim watts il ya toujours un
élément nouveau qui émergent à la
lecture des archives le premier article
évoquait un chargement d'alcool mais ce
qu'ils avaient retenu l'attention du
journaliste c'était la découverte d'une
malle remplie de robes dans ces temps de
superstition ont parlé vite de mahler
lorsqu'une femme monter à bord il ya un
autre élément qui a poussé les gens de
l'époque a parlé même de malédiction
dans ce mystère c'est que le premier
article sur le sujet paru un vendredi 13
et cet article était très sommaire il
parlait de la marie céleste et dans
quelles circonstances le bateau avait
été retrouvé et par la suite on a parlé
des indices à bord comme cet ep avec des
tâches qui ressemblait à du sang
ce qui ressort surtout des premiers
commentaires c'est que rien n'était en
désordre les bouteilles n'était pas
renverser il n'y avait pas de dégâts sur
le bateau
le journal a également couvert l'enquète
du tribunal oui bien sûr
c'est à partir de là que les choses ont
vraiment commencé et ça à jeter les
soupçons sur l'équipage qui avaient
trouvé là marie céleste
le procureur n'était pas convaincu par
ce qu'il avait entendu
en mer ce qu'ils trouvaient un bateau
abandonné touché une forte récompense la
cour a soupçonné les marins du bateau
sauveteur d'avoir fait disparaître
l'équipage de la marie céleste pour
toucher les 30000 dollars de la prime la
solution de l'énigme se trouve
certainement dans ce manuscrit original
c'est le rapport complet de l'enquète
que jim se plaît à lire entre les lignes
[Musique]
je pense qu'un autre élément intéressant
à propos de cette histoire
c'est que le procureur mister soli flood
un homme de caractère
affectionner l'idée que la boisson avait
quelque chose à voir là dedans
parce que le bateau transportait de
l'alcool je crois qu'il pensait cela
parce que lui même était plutôt portée
sur la bouteille et ils pouvaient
facilement imaginer que l'ivresse des
marins causerait forcément des problèmes
il était obsédé par cette idée
ce tribunal n'a finalement pas retenu
son hypothèse mais le procureur n'en
démordez pas et il a tout fait pour
imposer son point de vue est proche
la cour a conclu par un non lieu l'épée
ne portaient que des traces de rouille
finalement la justice est restée
impuissante
il ya eu comme un grand vide et
l'imagination c'est d'inconnus a horreur
du vide
jim s'est battu contre toutes les
rumeurs
il a ouvert un site au tout début
d'internet pour collecter une mine
d'informations il a même créé un
logiciel pour calculer le lest des
navires est prouvé que la marie céleste
n'avait pas souffert d'une avarie liés
au chargement
mais même sur son site les esprits ont
chauffé
en
fait personne ne sait ce qui s'est passé
mais tout le monde a son idée là dessus
on a parlé d'un calamar géant qui aurait
surgi et terrifié l'équipage
on a parlé d'un geyser sous-marin
le kidnapping de l'équipage par des
extraterrestres est une théorie qui a eu
beaucoup de succès je ne vois pas bien
pourquoi il l'aurait fait
une théorie plus plausible est apparue
récemment scène d'un tremblement de
terre sous-marin qui auraient pu secouer
le bateau très fortement à tel point que
l'équipage aurait pensé que le
chargement était en train d'exploser et
tout le monde aurait paniqué et
abandonné le navire
comment une histoire comme celle de la
marie céleste plonge dans le surnaturel
il suffit parfois d'un sacré talent de
conteur
[Musique]
aligné un mètre de l'en quête s'est
emparé de la sphère douze ans après la
découverte de la marie céleste
le père de sherlock holmes conan doyle
lui même enquêté à sa manière
seul arthur conan doyle écrit nouvelle
publiée dans un journal qui va
passionner les foules
le mystère de la marie céleste ressurgit
c'est en france à quelques kilomètres de
montpellier que se tient la rencontre
annuelle des passionnés de sherlock
holmes
en
des membres sont venus de toute la
france parfois de l'étranger pour se
rassembler autour de thierry saint
joanis le président de la confrérie
tout y passe la casquette du héros ces
enquêtes et cette petite nouvelle dans
laquelle commandes hall met en scène un
cuisinier qui assassinent tous les
membres de la marie céleste
à sa parution l'auteur ne va pas signer
sa fiction et tous les lecteurs vont
croire le mystère enfin résolu ce qu'on
sait à l'époque c'est que les passagers
ont disparu du bateau une dizaine de
jours avant qu'on le retrouve mes conan
doyle a une idée et pour que son
histoire fonctionne il le maudit fait un
peu la réalité
lui romance en fait ce fait divers et il
va imaginer
que le bateau de sauvetage découvre le
bateau vide mais
trouve des indices qui laissent penser
que les passages ans disparu il ya
quelques minutes on retrouve des tasses
de thé avec du thé encore chaud ce qui
prouve que des gens étaient de 3 minutes
avant prêt à le boire on retrouve un
chat qui est là qui n'a pas souffert de
de la nourriture qui a été entretenue
encore très récemment koné de
volontairement
rajoute des éléments pour que son
histoire puisse fonctionner et s et ce
quitte plus tard et on va troubler pas
mal de chercheurs qui vont oublier que
c'était une fiction et vont prendre pour
argent comptant ce qui est écrit dans
cette nouvelle
loin de résoudre le problème quand on
donne va léguer à tous les enquêteurs de
la marie céleste un véritable sac de
noeuds
en 1956 une émission scientifique de
l'eau et rtf revient sur cette énigme en
reconstituant la découverte de la marie
céleste les auteurs mettent en scène
sans le savoir l'imagination débordante
de conan doyle
[Applaudissements]
il était chaud se tait
indiscutablement show
versés depuis moins d'une heure
et pourtant il n'y avait personne sur ce
bateau sur sept maris céleste camp et de
découvrir en plein atlantique
si vous devez bien nous allons quand
même examiner les différentes hypothèses
qui ont été exposés au cours de
l'émission est de 1 en plus d'une heure
et demie les célèbre historien andré
castelot et alain decaux vont débattre
d'après des éléments tronqués une chose
est irréfutable avec lamari céleste plus
rien n'est vraiment sûr
est le symbole
le bateau fantôme s'est dérobé à toutes
les enquêtes
le mystère de la marie céleste n'a pas
fini de hanter les esprits les murs de
chypre altar
[Musique]
depuis ce jour de décembre 1872 d'autres
bateaux fantômes sont apparus sur les
mers en 1917 le débris n'a été retrouvé
vide en 1921 on ne trouve plus trace de
l'équipage du carol à des rings malgré
six enquêtes du gouvernement fédéral
américain en 1940 le gloria cola il
connaît la même mésaventure dans le
pacifique en 1953 le ocz ou dérive au
large des îles nicobar un repas est sur
le point d'être servis mais le bateau
est vide en 2006 le jiangxi est retrouvé
au large du queensland
tiens tiens les 12 membres d'équipage se
sont volatilisés et puis le petit
dernier le case de
ici sur les rivages du queensland
australien le procès touche à sa fin
le tribunal de tar en dessous il vient à
l'instant de rendre ses conclusions
tu peux dire que le tribunal déclare que
les hommes sont tombés du bateau
et se sont noyés
pour la cour les trois plaisanciers sont
deux quarts est mort accidentellement
les familles vont pouvoir faire leur
deuil
nous tenons à remercier tous les gens
qui nous ont soutenu
nos amis et tous les membres des
familles
l enquête a répondu à certaines
questions
nous remercions les juges pour leur
compréhension
les conclusions sont assez conforme à ce
que nous attendions
merci
comment vous vous sentez maintenant
merci c'est terminé
une noyade collective
ça vous fichent comme un doute collectif
le premier homme serait tombé à l'eau
empêchant le deuxième en portant secours
premier et le troisième en voulant
repêcher les deux autres
c'est la version officielle et elle sera
certainement très commentée dans le
monde des plaisanciers
trois bonhommes qui se noie l'un après
l'autre c'est plutôt une histoire à
dormir debout
justement le sommeil il y en a qui vont
avoir du mal à le trouver cette nuit
il ya encore tant de mystère autour de
cette affaire
on ne sait toujours pas ce qui s'est
passé
le case deux têtes au large et des
questions restent sans réponse encore
aujourd'hui
la société en général la mondialisation
a fait qu'on est tous interconnectés au
courant de tout à tout heure
les médias couvrent toutes les
actualités c'est phénoménal
le moindre bruit le moindre événement
est rapportée films et aux mises en
ligne mais dans l'océan au large on est
à l'écart de tout cela on est loin des
médias loin de toute cette agitation et
des projecteurs
l'océan garde tous ses mystères car
c'est un lieu où l'on peut encore
s'échapper
cette histoire est celle de trois hommes
qui prennent la mer et disparaissent
sans laisser de trace et sans qu'on ne
les revoit plus jamais
pour le case 2 pour la marie céleste et
les autres bateaux fantômes la solution
de l'énigme appartient à tout le monde
c'est un domaine public comme la mer